in the lobby of Ramsey solutions of
Steve and Amy are with us hey guys how
are ya we're doing great how are you
welcome welcome where're you guys from
Clinton Township Michigan oh cool
welcome to Nashville thank you and here
to do your debt-free screen we are I
love it how much have you paid off we
paid off seventy one thousand three
hundred and sixty nine dollars and some
change love it and how long did that
take 16 months good and your range of
income during that time we stuck right
around 110,000 cool what are you guys to
do for a living I'm a firefighter
hmm I'm a teacher very cool well good to
have you guys today congratulations what
kind of debt was the 71 that wasn't
dollars it was a lot of stupid tax I can
say we had credit card debt we had a
home equity loan to pay off that credit
card debt and then we got more credit
card debt and then we thought we'd
borrow against my deferred comp mm-hmm
we have two credit card debt so then you
got more credit care about okay yeah we
didn't break the cycle of why we were
charging you know do we found your
program cool very cool
well I'm glad you did that's that's good
so which one of the credit cards when
you paid them off
you went I hate you people I'm so glad
you're gone I think we have the Discover
card the longest yeah so and that was
although we we had that one gone already
and we were just basically down to one
credit card so it was nice just to to
cut it up and put them in our past bring
that whole thing that whole chapter to a
close sadly very good so what happened
sixteen months ago that made you change
your and change your evil ways Amy had
been hitting about your program for me
for a little while we had a friend that
went through it are some friends I
thought I had it under control I was one
the kind of did the budget and I just
assumed we were normal and then one day
at work you were yeah and then I had a
day at work where I had realization I
was eligible to retire in five years and
panic son and because
not only we had this debt we still had
our home of course we had to pay for we
have two kids quickly coming up to
college years and that's when I came
home it happened to be a Sunday morning
I says we should probably do that
program that you were talking about
surrender right so yeah we were making
it month by month but we were never
there zero attraction you know if
anything else we were slipping back
obviously as our debt kept slowly
accumulating Wow so you you the program
did you go through Financial Peace
University nine we program okay and we
jumped in at the deep end all the way we
figured if we're gonna do this let's try
it obviously what we were doing was not
working and if we didn't like what you
were teaching us we could always go back
and get back in back but we hit traction
hard and we started paying it off and it
was you know it was it was fun
almost to the point that toward the end
of the month we were you know if we
stuck to that budget this month we knew
how much we were gonna be able to put on
the the debt and if he came a game it
doesn't matter what you're doing when
you're successful at it it becomes fun
yeah because you're getting traction
right and you get those you get those
little milestones so Amy what it feel
like when Steve walks in on that Sunday
morning and goes okay let's do it
I was very mature I didn't say I told
you so I was very happy that we were
gonna finally do something like he said
he had been doing the most most of the
finances and I really I knew we were in
debt I didn't know how much that we were
really in that was a shocker for me when
we sat down after that first class and
wrote everything down and so I was glad
we had a plan and there were steps to
follow and that made it a lot easier
yeah I was foolish David you know
anytime we've had a problem in our
marriage we work together we always
accomplish the goal of far far further
than we expected so I don't know why I
didn't listen to her when she was giving
us you know giving me these hints that
hey maybe we should maybe we should try
something different I should have
listened to her as my fault
I'll take how long have you guys been
how long you guys been married 21 years
on
Thursday oh no happy Anniversary you
know cool so what that when you sat down
that first night and you look down at
the $71,000 this is huge mountain in
front of you yeah and you go hon and we
got to do a budget and we got to do this
and we got do that but we're gonna do it
we're all-in right right so what ended
up being easier than you thought it was
gonna be everything honestly everything
I don't want to see it's easy it's not
it's not a walk in the park but it was
nice to feel that sense of control and
that if anything was gonna go wrong it
was gonna be okay you know the day
there's a month after we paid off our
debt the the fridge just died and we
woke up and everything was lukewarm and
we just got in the car and took our
money and went and bought a fridge for
her before we would have put it on a
credit card and it wouldn't that was the
first thing they asked us they says you
know we do have 0% finance it
congratulations you guys very fun what
do you tell people the key to getting
out of debt is I think it's the budget
especially when you're doing at the
beginning of the month and you you
finally get to that spot where you have
a lot of money that at the end of the
month you're gonna be able put on your
debt it gives you that goal to stay on
the budget every month you know if
things come up sometimes it's a little
frustrating you have to adjust the
budget something comes up at work or
with the kids and you have to but you've
got that little bit of flex in there
that you can readjust it a little bit
Michael
less on to the debt but you know that at
the end of the month we're gonna be able
to knock this much out of the debt so
it's very very rewarding yeah that this
plan has to balance we're not in
Congress exactly but we got a plan yeah
right very cool very cool so all right
we're gonna give you a copy of Chris
Hogan's retire inspired books signed by
him which takes you to the next chapter
and okay thank you and a wealth of
funding and let's build some wealth and
increase your generosity to crazy levels
now your kids ages and names your kids
ages and names our daughter Erin she is
18 and our son Vinny is 15 okay are they
joining your they're just gonna watch
they're here they're watching they're
spectators
all right that's cool good deal all
right it's Steve and Amy from Detroit
Michigan $71,000 paid off in 16 months
making a hundred and ten a year count it
down let's hear a debt free scream ready
three two one boom just like that man oh
you love it love it love it love it very
very well done man that's just killer
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you can do this you know that
really is a message whether you've got
two hundred seventy thousand dollars in
student loan debt or 27 thousand well
you've got a fifty thousand dollar
income a five hundred thousand dollar
company